Một bẩy thằng chiến năm 2018, lãnh đạo hi bán như dân xả khánh lâm,
cà mong cho biết trên địa bản vừa xả vụ việc ông vỏ vẽ tình công hai mẹ con khiến người mẹ không qua khó.
Thế đó, sáng 1 xấu thằng chiến năm 2018, chỉ đe tay quyền, bà mẹ lâm tùy,
mùa xả khánh lâm, cùng trong biết luối thuê gần nhà và giấn theo con trai tay bế bế bế bế bà tùy.
Đến chơi cùng ngày, chi quy cung con trai di về nhà lấy cương thị bất ngờ bị tụ ông vỏ vẽ chương cây chạm bông bằng dưới xuống ngày trước mạnh.
Đàn ông lào và đốt hai mẹ con, phát hiện vụ việc người dân nhìn trong đưa cả hai đi cấp cứu như đàn hai dờ cung ngày, chỉ quy khu qua khó.
Khiểm tra, chỉ quy bị khoảng hai trong biết ông vỏ vẽ đốt, còn cho bế khoảng 5 miế bế đốt.
Người dân chính kiến cho biết, gió có con nhỏ đi cùng lên chỉ quy khu kì trại, còn cố lời thân mình chết chẳng cho con.
Chính vì vậy, chỉ bị đàn ông đốt nhiều hơn.
Thế lấy đạo bình biệt sản, như cảm au, hiện bế bế đã được nướng tử máy như mẹn gàn tăng cao, cân tích tục thật gió chả chả chế.
Rất những chi quy thuộc dự khó khăn ở đưa phương, bố trường chi quy khó bàng của con.
Sau sự việc chi quyền xác hệ lâm đã đến tham hỏa khó chở rất.